plumes of smoke billowing from the
central part of the valley Saturday
afternoon as the old Kmart Building
located off Sahara and the cloud went up
in Flames just before three o'clock
Clark County Fire Department along with
Las Vegas fire and rescue arrived on
scene to the three-alarmed fire that
received a high-level response due to
the size of the Blaze and its location
in the Attic part of the building when
they realized it was appearing they
might be expected so they called a
second alarm and then a third alarm
which brought us a total of 76 people to
include 12 engine companies four ladder
trucks four Battalion Chiefs two air
resources and three rescues residents
nearby recall what they saw and say just
because the building is vacant doesn't
mean there isn't a fair share of people
hanging around it from time to time I
didn't realize what was going on and I
looked over across the street and it was
like 30 feet high Flames I've been
living here for about six years and then
people go in and out of this building so
I mean who knows ccfd sharing with eight
news now that Saturday's wet weather
made for a much easier time putting out
the Flames but the lack of water from
nearby hydrants posed a challenge for
those on scene we had to hook up to some
of the yellow hydrants to get our water
supplies uh not sure why there were some
we call them like dead hydrants not sure
why they were but they weren't so we
just had to just a little bit more host
tonight and there was no injuries a
civilian or firefighters no additional
Properties or residences were damaged as
a result of the nearby Flames but there
was a partial collapse of the building's
roof and the building is considered
unstable at this time the cause of the
fire is still under investigation
the deputy fire chief sharing with me
that they plan on being out here past
midnight tonight tending to all the hot
spots as they expect hot spots and
flare-ups to continue throughout this
week reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now